[Music]
isn't about time these assholes merge
these two logos into one and spare us
the forty-five seconds it takes to suck
their own nice hot cake guilt cake this
shutting Jesus another fish is gone
missing speak me feel like the NSA dude
at the end of Hunt for Red October
you've lost another submarine hi I'm
dory can you please help me Finding Nemo
opened with a gut-punching emotional
scene of loss of life setting the
urgency tone early this movie opens with
the scene of a forgetful child then cuts
straight to her being alone we could
have done itself tons of favors by
showing us the actual moment Dory lost
track of her family but instead we just
lost that daughter she could come from
anywhere Wow you are you are no help
today movie gets terrific comic actors
Bill Hader and Kate McKinnon - voice
fish but then gives them nothing else to
do in the whole movie which is a waste
the sin is for the fact that her blindly
trusting ass hasn't been gobble hole by
a bigger fish yet the idea that fish
come up to the surface to stare at the
stars that's actually laughably stupid
but whatever good milky way shot Pixar
you're perfect I'm dory
was it something I said no it was you
popping out of nowhere suddenly thereby
scaring them are you stupid
in addition to having memory issues
Finding Nemo origins a whole year making
it a whole year is going to make it very
hard for me to swallow the dory will be
successful in finding her parents also
be telling me that after the original
Finding Nemo adventures she's managed to
stick around but then a whole year after
that she's gonna wander off think
seriously about three sharks no no there
were definitely four last time he told
it there were three movie decides
Marlene is a compulsive liar which was
not a trait he displayed prior to this
movie but whatever sequels got to find
humor where they can almost miss field
trip
even though Dory got you up early where
are we going I thought you told I didn't
tell her yeah Marlon but why did you
bring her here if you told her she
couldn't go on the field trip anyway and
has it Nemo been through enough she
could have made this trip on his own I
mean one year later says how I am so
honored I have never been a teaching
assistant before mr. Wray you got help
Marlon who has absolutely nothing to do
gives up on trying to tell dory she
can't go on this field trip after one
misunderstanding but I guess he's busy
and all with all the many anemone
amenities back at home you see kids when
two fish love each other man will stop
right there
apparently dory who was never taught
about reproduction knows about
reproduction and also the act of egg
fertilization is given the same Puritan
embarrassment as human reproduction even
though these kids are a year older and
should already know this I remembered
something luckily this class mr. ray
taught today contained exactly the sort
of clues Dory needed to kick-start her
journey and she doesn't forget them
within seconds making her memory in this
movie super convenient something
important what how's Marlon here right
now did he get a premonition about
checking on mr. Ray's field trip and
somehow find all these assholes then
somehow found Dory even though she was
carried into the undertow and a mass of
stingrays somewhere out there is my
family it's a massively ginormous ocean
though do you really think you can
strike finding a missing fish goal twice
also it takes nearly 1/3 of this finding
Dory movie for Dory to even go looking
for herself you can get us all the way
across the ocean right no but I know a
guy good thing it's been a whole year
and these turtles are migrating again
huh also as happy as I am to see dude
crush again he rides the East Australian
current and shouldn't have anything
knowledge or ability to get these fish
to California sea turtles are not an
entire globe inhabited species sequel to
Finding Nemo perpetuates the myth of
clownfish being able to hold on to
turtle shells during this speedy tubular
journey
squirt hasn't aged a day in the last
year I'm concerned about his growth in
lack of nutrition Dory somehow doesn't
see or doesn't react to this scary giant
ass eyeball that appears right in her
field of view while Marlene is talking
once again predator decides to announce
itself instead of just killing these
fish right now have you ever seen that
show animal ninja warriors yeah of
course don't announce their presence
they just suddenly snapped and they're
dead 20,000 Leagues Under the
entertainment value also fortunately for
the scene setting an entire cargo ship
at all its containers sunk here and all
those containers have stayed stacked on
the ship despite the 45-degree angle
this is why you don't bring your child
on intercontinental ocean adventures
physics ex machina you can go wait over
there go wait over there and forget it's
what you do best
this is super mean for a fish that's
lived near her and called her friend and
tolerated her forgetfulness for an
entire year and now of course she's
going to get just far enough to get
separated from them to cause further
calamity all because Marlin was an
uncharacteristic dick I'm sick warning
neither why is audio intended for human
guests of the park so audible from
outside and underwater other than to
advance the plot I mean do they actually
have speakers underwater so all the fish
can hear this too where we believe in
rescue rehabilitation and release except
all the fish who can help Dory find her
parents
they aren't released yet that would be
silly and why would a marine life
Institute in California have a picture
on the wall of the Australian dentists
nice from the first movie and how old is
that apple 2e computer back there octopi
can camouflage but that's very different
from complete invisibility there wasn't
even a telltale lumpier meaning this
octopus can also camouflage his 3d body
into something 2d if I just take your
tag I can take your place on the
transport truck how the hell does he
think he's getting this tag off this is
one of those super impossible cable ties
no maybe it's because he's not too puss
he doesn't know that but he does know
something about Cleveland and
understands human speech so you can
forgive us for being assholes about that
I suffer from short-term memory loss
it's kind of a drag she has to keep
saying this over and over because it
makes the movie kind of boring
we're supposed to be releasing the
octopus back to the ocean today amazing
this octopus was planning his Prison
Break on the very day Dory got captured
and these two could start some sort of
symbiotic relationship
how does Hank look green when his
camouflage takes the color of his
surroundings there's no green here
except for on the map and it's not in
range by the way nice job making the
octopus basically Randall from monsters
Inc
look shells huh Jesus this movie is like
momento across with Slumdog Millionaire
Dory's memory is inconvenient until the
world which is conducting some sort of
parental scavenger hunt provides perfect
clues at the perfect time base this is
Carol missing octopus oh what a liar
when did you ever see the octopus during
this walk down the stairs yeah you might
have stepped on octopus goop
but you didn't get visual confirmation
so stop lying you lying liar hmm destiny
oh destiny destiny is not only the name
of a whale dory knows but the mantra by
which this screenplay was written Dori
knocks over the coffeepot without
breaking it or making a noise and
absolutely nobody will wonder wife and
coffee pot is suddenly here this
employee can't hear Hanks grunts and
loud ass monkey barring also this
octopus is so James Bond I'm wondering
how he hasn't broken out of this place
on his own yet or found and put himself
in whatever tank he's trying to get to
and then this person absent mindedly
throws a regal blue tang out into the
whale shark tank
I mean people look at things right
friends know we've talked through the
pipes when we were little we were pen
pals
because aquarium rehab places like this
always have pipes connecting each
exhibit for easy marine life
communication of course also know you
weren't pipe pals you fucking weren't
you you were not Dory's little voice
couldn't carry that far or even helped
Horton here who much less be piped pals
with a whale shark ocean exhibit hmm
fish with a memory problem a shark with
an eyesight problem Nemo's weak fin it's
almost as if these movies think
disabilities are easy joke fodder I'm
sorry but there's no other way there's
no other way now this movie is getting
fucking ridiculous like Dory spent a
whole year not hearing anything that
reminded her of her parents now she's
had a virtual treasure trove of memory
joggers in one day and maybe the movie
is saying her memory is simply just
getting better but it's still a
ridiculous amount of reminders in a
short amount of time what are we even
doing we're cooling along in the animal
kingdom the pronoun game is a huge
problem even worse than poaching or
overfishing
Nikki keeps humorously pecking Marlatt
but isn't this beak of beak like tear
fish and other small prey apart gotta be
all you have to do is imprint with at
night oh man they drank Twilight
Breaking Dawn too into this didn't they
Jackley is becky supposed to carry us oh
man how many lost fish have broken their
way into quarantine using becky and a
sand pail these sea lions make it sound
like all the time hey movie how did
these two get out of the tank and across
the massive human walkway to hide in the
stroller I know you glossed over it but
I cannot still not clear these assholes
watching two amazingly large sea
creatures are not in any way dumbfounded
at this kind of behavior right now just
the belugas posture alone with its fin
in the air would make me want to call
the park authorities mad on the loose
baby stroller driving through families
and other moms but nobody gives a hey
the world's most powerful pair of I know
that why do I know that no idea since
you were just a little baby when you
left and I can't think of one reason why
you'd ever see that sign while in
captivity this feels sort of like the
traffic cone thing in Toy Story 2 where
miraculously no one is observant and no
one even as much just walks by this tree
with a pail of fish in it tree limb has
unreal catapulting powers and insane
accuracy by throwing Marlon and Nemo
into a fish tank but would definitely be
sitting around outside a gift shop but
thank goodness they landed in water am i
right what are the odds of that by the
way I believe my disbelief has served
its proper suspension when it comes to
this octopus driven stroller that no one
in this entire building notices and is
now on full alert Bullock status lucky
alcove of wackiness that's it
you have wasted my time wait no that
transport truck leaves it gone and I'm
not missing it so give me your tag I
honestly can't argue with a single thing
this guy says here why would a spiky
fish like this be put in the children's
touch pool do you want to get sued
because this is how you get sued she
remembers that just keep swimming song
from her childhood and decides that his
advice for her current situation and
despite all logic it apparently is you
made her feel like she couldn't do it
didn't we cover this in the first movie
we're really covering it again seriously
she would just look at the first thing
she sees and it's at this point Jeremy
lost his ability to sigh this is a sigh
moma the movie thoroughly extinguished
all of them in the first 30 minutes so
I've been forced to do it sigh gave all
hold on to me physics
right this tag comes off way too easily
considering what we know about it which
is way too much my parents are actually
down there probably not actually but
whatever there we go now if you ever get
lost doors by doors parents not being in
this tank for quite some time the shells
they let out still managed to keep their
trail over a whole year that why you're
not in quarantine quarantine the ex
Malkin is in this movie could fill a
whole series of Harry Potter novels
sorry hello pipe bouncing saves the day
with a lucky whale who uses echolocation
in the other tank I mean I'd settle for
a convenient trail of Reese's Pieces at
this point also thankfully for dory in
this movie this beluga figures out his
echolocation abilities at just the right
time oh thank god it's Marlin a Nemo but
why the fuck did dude's echolocation
show a much larger fish this whole time
was it for suspense purposes I bet it
was you've shown me how to do stuff I
never dreamed of doing outsmarting
sharks and jumpin jellyfish yeah those
would be called lucky not some sort of
amazing intellectual survival skills you
made all that happen ditching I think
the sea turtles the Pelican and the
dentist tank fish deserve a lot more
credit than you're giving them here I
mean did you even see the last movie
this is it man just in time to be
guarded away to you were about five
seconds away from being on the floor in
debt but luck is so much on your side
you should buy a fish lottery ticket
right now my family and it's
miraculously lit unlike all the other
loser tanks in here who do you think
major all these open-topped fish tanks
were in the right order for this
progression of jumps the screenwriter or
God I want to know what kind of marine
life Institute leaves up King that of
mop water lying around during working
hours when the janitors aren't even here
yet also let's not forget all the
nastiness that is in this mop water that
would likely kill fish and is dumped
into another fish tank later
dilution can only do so much people tell
me
that was years ago they never came back
how long have these blue tangs been in
the ml I to know the Dory story and just
now the Institute decides and we'll take
him to Cleveland allmovie long door he's
been talking about her parents and
calling them by name but suddenly she
forgets Marlon and Nemo and his conclude
because the plot needs her to be Dory
gets out to the open sea and is so
unsure of what to do that I'm positive
she's about to accidentally herself into
her parents Dory was thrown out of the
quarantine and down a sewer grate and
funneled out into the sea where she
couldn't remember anything except what
would Dory do miraculously this leads
her to some kill which leads her to a
magic seashell which leads her to her
parents who just happened to be here all
these years
I'm all for Dory doing this without help
but this officially broke me watching
this movie way to lucky everything in
this movie is way to lucky with the
numerous seashell trails wouldn't she
have seen one of these well before she
actually did there are so many trails
here that finding any particular one
should have been easier than the miracle
that appeared to be a minute ago also
all shells lead to the Drowned radial
tire wait what okay the parents put this
together and hung out here for years
just in case Dory somehow came here this
is like the parable of the talent and
these parents are the ones that buried
their talent which did not impress the
master it's a big thing ocean y'all last
movie we saw what a real parent does
when a child goes missing he goes
looking for them when the dories dad's
eyes turn hazel or whatever the color is
why do you think we stayed tortue here
all these years instead of going to the
MLI and finding a way back in the
exhibit which would have been way more
logical considering the problem-solving
skills of fish in these movies but
Marlon and Nemo
oh yeah the problem that makes this
movie feel longer than it is see when
they found me it felt like fate do you
know what I mean oh what's another word
for fate like destiny oh we all knew
what you meant by fate but somehow that
triggers your thesaurus and bills you
out of yet another Jam it's your destiny
destiny writes itself
with this whale's echolocation work this
well above water don't get used to it
general
Chiqui Joe why are these California sea
lions British Oh way to stop traffic
this is something that I highly doubt a
beluga whale a whale shark and a blue
tang we'll be able to figure out
considering this is human stuff they've
never encountered but Dory gets the
bright idea to use these X mocking
honors to stop traffic oh honey you're
not believing us again this is actually
exactly like Marlin doubting Nemo at the
climax of the first movie is so
paint-by-numbers even Bob Ross looks
down on it from heaven
these otters willingly stand in traffic
to stop it for a fish they never met
yeah those things just appeared out of
nowhere well within your sight one
minute ago
also these otters are looking dead these
cars are going too damn fast to prevent
roadkill right now apparently the otters
also knew they needed to hug in the
street or else their natural cuteness
would not have been enough
none of this glass breaks after this
ruff stop by the truck I'll forgive the
cartoon speed at which this bird showed
up but I will not forgive the fact that
this bird hurt Marlins call in the first
place Dori follow me but of course she
doesn't follow because this movie is an
aggressive dickhead to stuff like ending
okay kid I guess this is goodbye
no what do you mean not the assholes who
shoot away the otters a minute ago
decided F get there's a multi-million
dollar animated aquatic adventure going
on so we'll leave the doors open for a
record amount of time to allow all that
to happen what is so great about plans I
never had a plan thing that I understand
told the writers when this movie began
production somehow finds its way into
the script also do they have time for
this windows time get invented in this
world the best things happen by chance
because that's life this movie's message
seriously that we shouldn't plan for
stuff and just take life as it comes
while I recognize the problems with over
planning this is a terrible terrible
message to send to kids I see this
movie's a 1:13 gag is here so a few
dozen animators across the country can
jerk off now
I dress this what which where we gone
this Joyride doesn't end with 20 people
and numerous species of fish dead all
these fish switched tanks which is
definitely hilarious but none of them
fall or break this truck jumps to
concrete highway barriers and keeps
going that's bull then the goddamn fish
tanks inside again go unscathed it's
like this movie was made just to test my
patience and the movie is one seagulls
she goes off and fly in from the ocean
at least as often as they fly out to the
ocean
but hey you had a 50-50 chance and you
needed a lucky brick the cop responds to
a stolen truck is mesmerizingly fast and
despite the fact that they had no idea
where this truck was gone
they managed to set up a roadblock in
this direction sweet I enjoy this what a
wonderful world slow-motion shot as much
as the next guy but these doors were
locked from the outside damn it they did
not fall open during a free fall all
these fish miraculously missed the rock
on which these sea lions are perched you
can do what ever you put your mind to
another terrible message to send to kids
because that's patently untrue if my kid
sees this movie and then puts his mind
to jumping off a building to fly
huh-huh-huh
it really is quite a view of what blurry
water as far as the eye can see you fish
need to get out more okay props in
respect to this movie for giving us fun
visuals underneath much of the end
credits something not enough movies do
once in remove how are these assholes
not dead fish gets lost and needs
rescuing by other fish teacher-man
erasings the same melody cat pelagic
method pelagic after your physical
education migration would learn about
migration a comedic side character uses
a single word and repetition to create
the sound we humans think of as their
standard call set in frantic attack from
a predator during said attack Dory has a
stretchy item on her head
crucial directions provided by crush
captive main characters help her fish
has a disability rescue fish carried in
water and flown by bird to save the day
ticks are shames humanity with casual
ocean garbage
Christa's righteous Rogers Rogers Rogers
Rogers crucial well assistance by
turning reliance on strangers initially
the disabled helper creature has selfish
motives we're all gonna escape you have
wasted my time wait no that transport
truck leaves it gone human kids are
terrible to fish and octopus is made to
ink when he's not ready therapy picks it
has been 3 weeks since my last fish oh
my onna
main character find self in open ocean
near climax and total despair main
characters help her fish break out of
their confinement heroes have to follow
a white human vehicle multiple good fish
chant something over and over
[Music]
unprocessed fish sticks
I remembered something
memory can change the shape of a room it
can change the color of a car
my memories can be distorted I'm just an
interpretation they're not a record I
don't want to forget this somewhere out
there is my family ah what what do we do
what would Tori do what would Brian
Boitano do if he was here right now we'd
make a plan and follow through that's
what my book follow the shells follow
the yellow brick road
hey where's dory she would you boom
click big good strong hand don't they
I'm your density